Thanks okay yeah so thanks everybody and
so apologies in advance this is so
Chinmay and joaquin both really wanted
to be here Chinmay was sick and his son
was sick and Joaquin just hours ago had
some emergency so I'm very much flying
by the seat of my pants here so
apologies in advance but I'll do the
best I can so this is basically Claudine
was going to talk about the machine
learning side of Facebook and Shinmei
was going to talk about the auction side
and so so my background
sohe Keynes in machine learning groups
in maze in this ads delivery product
group I'm in this economic research
group so I'm definitely not as
intimately familiar with either of these
areas but I'm at least on the auction
side I'm working you know with Chinmay
so I can at least even if the
presentation is a little bit rough
hopefully please ask questions if things
are unclear and hopefully I'll be able
to answer them as best I can
okay so as I said the the talk is
basically broken down into this machine
learning side how do we predict various
things that we care about on Facebook
probabilities that users are going to be
doing different things and then given
those predictions as input how do we
actually decide what content to show a
given user okay so a high level we can
sort of think about Facebook as this
personalized newspaper and so
essentially all this really means is we
want some individual content for for
each person and each person cares about
different stories in different ways so
if I come to Facebook maybe there
there's two possible worlds that I could
be in one is where I see these stories
on the left one is where I see these
stories on the right and so our question
is which of these should we actually
show a user when they come to Facebook
right and so some of the you know maybe
this person on the left is you know
maybe this story itself isn't that
interesting but maybe it's a close tie
or something like that
and so it's really a challenging problem
here
but what we want to show people is the
stories that they're actually caring
about and not showing them the things
you know all the the other noise
essentially and so for a long time
actually this wasn't really an issue
because we just showed all users
everything just in reverse chronological
order as I think Twitter had done as
well and eventually it just got to be
too much so so there are people that
have complained when we switched to this
sort of ranking version because you're
not seeing everything and there is this
risk that maybe we show you something
that or maybe we don't show you
something that you would have wanted to
have seen but the reality is just a
given person has on average 1,500
stories that they could potentially see
in a given day and so we've run
experiments on this without ranking you
know people click comment and like
things significantly less often than
they do when we have this ranking people
miss an important stories or stories
that we deem to be important people see
content that we think is irrelevant you
know maybe you don't care that you
someone that you went to junior high
with had a carrot cake for lunch or
whatever it may be and so you know that
this is why ranking is important
essentially we have to figure out what
stories to actually be showing the user
and as I said there are different so
different users have different
preferences so one person may only like
updates that are coming from is his
clothes his or her close personal
friends someone else may really have an
interest in news stories someone else
may you know that they actually have
value for these stories that are coming
from weak ties and they you want to get
the diversity in stories someone else
maybe really likes funny cat videos
somebody else
I guess likes clicking cows I didn't
make these slides also as a preface but
but I think what this is trying to get
at is you know some very specific
preferences that people have and these
interests that
you know this would be the ideal as
knowing these sorts of things about
individual users but we don't have a way
to actually get at this specific of
preferences we don't ask an individual
user what sort of things they care about
other there are some ways for users to
express their preferences so we can't
make these sorts of decisions for
everybody we just don't have that you
know we can't measure that so but what
we can measure are the things that we
observe happening on Facebook right so
these different what what are called
feed Met feed metrics so just different
things happening in feed right we see
when somebody clicks on a given story
through to a news article or clicks on a
link to a video when somebody likes a
given story we see that when someone
comments on a story when somebody shares
a story how long someone is viewing a
story we see how if there's a video how
long they've watched it and so we we
have these are sort of the observables
that we have and we could think about
users having you know this is some
indication of the value that the user is
having by they're giving some signal
that they like something by by liking it
on Facebook so basically the machine
learning part of this then is predicting
the probability that these different
events occur right so you know it's just
simple CTR prediction is one example of
this right and it's just we have other
events aside from clicks that we also
want to be predicting okay so if we have
these predictions of some probability of
all these different events occurring we
want to say what the value that a given
user has for seeing this story and so
Facebook is very much you know get about
incremental improvement just getting
something out there and and you know
revising it as as we go so this is sort
of what started out was somebody with
some some good intuition hopefully of
the system decided that well alike is
five times the value of a click a
comment is four times the value
like if you are hiding a story then
that's very bad and so these this is
basically some linear utility function
that we're thinking about where we've
sort of decided you know some somebody
on this team has decided upon these
coefficients essentially so there's sort
of an interesting thing here where so
I'm mostly gonna be talking about this
left-hand column for the first part of
the talk anyway right so we have these
relatively sophisticated models for
coming up with these probabilities the
question is like when you're multiplying
them by these sort of hand-picked
coefficients you know maybe there's room
for some improvement there so I can talk
online if you want about what you know
there has been some some improvements on
this where now there's sort of a I guess
reveal preferences approach of trying to
back out some more meaningful values for
these underlying events but I'll be
talking a little bit at a high level
about these event predictions okay so
the example that Joaquin was gave here
is actually I guess timely given Star
Wars this I think's I'm coming out soon
but so so basically we have the this is
a possible story on Facebook for those
of you that are unfamiliar this is one
thing that you can do is sort of
associate some relationship that you
have with another user on Facebook so
here Luke has added this other user
Darth as his father on Facebook and
there may be some other user say Yoda
that can potentially see this story as
well as you know a number of other
stories of other people that Yoda is
friends with so the question is should
we show Yoda this story and I've already
said that the way that we're going to
think about this is this this linear
utility function so probability of a
like x the value of a like and I said
for for now we're just sort of we've
chosen this value for a like and so
we're really just trying to figure out
what the probability of a like is here
and so how do we actually do this so
basically there's
few different types of features at the
hot at a high level that are mainly
looking at historical data right so the
first thing is the relationship between
Yoda and Luke right so there have been
previous stories that Yoda has seen from
Luke say these three stories here and
maybe Yoda has liked two of those three
stories right so that's our first signal
second is the relationship between Yoda
and this type of relationship story
right so maybe if we look at the data on
Yoda he's liked 50% of these
relationship stories that have come
through as opposed to when he sees a
someone posting a photo maybe he only
likes 10% of those stories birthday
posts he sees a lot of those he doesn't
care he likes point one percent of those
so this is sort of the second piece is
the the relative amount that Yoda is
liking this type of story so the third
high level feature is has nothing to do
with Yoda but it has to do with the
story right what historically have other
people done when they see this story so
maybe these five people around the
border here had also had previously seen
this story about Luke adding Darth as
his father and two of them liked it and
three of them didn't right so this is at
a very high level these are sort of the
types of at least base features that
we're thinking about when we're trying
to predict these things so that's sort
of a very high level you know we want to
show these stories you care about
nothing else and the main way we're
getting at these predictions so we have
this linear utility function and sort of
handpicking the coefficients as I
described it here using some of these
features to predict the probabilities of
these different things and so the
metrics here are these observables that
we actually have trying to get at the
value
I'm sorry X is here just mean that did
not like ya so sorry that's ambiguous so
it is not the case that they liked it
they just saw it and did nothing say
yeah but but there could be it's this
linear combination right so there's it's
not just like sigh I didn't show this
other prediction of the probability that
somebody hides the story and but it's a
similar sort of thing where you know
we'll try to estimate what the
probability is that this user hides the
story based on how he's height he or she
has hid things in the past and how
others have hid that particular story
all right any any questions about that
so far yes every user have some sort of
interaction with everything on his feet
or not and would every user so would we
like it to be the case that users are
interacting with everything like one
comment the next like have some sort of
interaction with everything on my feed
so if you actually interact with stories
that if you hide things you don't like
and you like things you do like if
everything is working it should be the
case that you see better content because
of that so yeah if you're you're
supplying more data essentially to the
predictions so yeah so high things you
don't like basically is will improve
your stories you see hopefully create
some kind of a selection problem that
we're going to only see stories that we
like should we throw in a story that
somebody doesn't like everyone's to know
in order to yeah that's a good question
so okay so I guess you're you're
thinking like maybe in this extreme case
I I have these very homogeneous
preferences and now it turns out that I
am you know seeing nothing essentially
but stories from Darth Vader or
something like that are from Luke yeah
that's a good point
so I am NOT in intimately familiar
enough with the the how the models are
trained but I imagine there's some
exploration that's being done that's a
good point
maybe I tend to like things that you
know these have a specific personalized
and so of course there's like a deep set
of possible features yeah so so this is
sort of a at a very high level some of
the types of features that are used so
actually one advantage of this system is
that it's very easy to experiment with
new features and that's that was sort of
one of Joaquin's main takeaways
basically was that the system that has
been built has allows for very rapid
experimentation where if you have some
idea for a feature you can basically get
it in the system as fast as you can
think of it and so if you have some
additional features like that you can
throw it in and test it it's relatively
easy to do alright so so so far I've
been talking about these organic stories
so so what is the you know my value for
seeing some user-generated content and
we can ask the same thing about ads
though right
and so I think the Joaquin was
originally giving some example here of
sort of the ideal case of an
that that he saw so looking at least
used to have a hearing aid and it just
so happened that he saw an ad for this
you know discreet hearing aid that's
affordable that yeah he essentially had
no prior knowledge of this and it's not
something that he would have gone to
search engine and searched for and so
this is just something that you know he
he found to be you know something where
you you don't necessarily have intent
but there is still potentially a lot of
value of seeing ads on Facebook and this
is sort of the ideal we would like all
ads to be like this of course that
doesn't always happen okay another thing
to note about the ads is just the scale
of what we're dealing with here so
there's over two million advertisers in
the system advertisers have multiple ads
so at any given point when a user comes
there's tens of millions of ads that we
have to choose from we have a billion
people that are coming to the site daily
so this results in every day having
trillions of ads that we have to come up
with predictions for so the point is
whatever we do it really has to scale
and it has to be fast
and furthermore it has to be accurate
right because especially when we're
talking about the on the outside of
things as well so this is sort of a
pointer forward to the the second half
of this but you know if you're familiar
with sponsored search as well it's you
know if we're predicting incorrectly
some probability that this ad is going
to get clicked we're sort of incorrectly
boosting it and potentially showing it
over some other ad that the user would
have preferred seeing so this is
essentially let's see so this is sort of
part of what the advertiser this is part
of the interface that the advertiser
sees so the first point here is to note
that advertisers can bid for different
events different objectives so here this
particular advertiser is maybe bidding
for users liking its page that's what it
has value for and so we're essentially
converting this into so there's some
value that the advertiser has for a like
there's some probability that we think
there's going to be alike given an
impression so this is basically the same
sort of utility function that we were
thinking about before except now instead
of those coefficients that we were using
the advertisers just expressing what its
value is for these different events
okay and the other point is just that
ads are created all the time and so we
have to be able to learn very quickly
what the probabilities of these
different events are the probability of
yes yep so so basically the the question
is yeah for what is the probability that
this advertiser will have this event
occur in this particular context say
here on the page so this is I'll say
this is the the piece that I'm least
familiar with but essentially there are
a few different models that have been
tried this is just starting with a very
simple logistic regression so the main
point is right things have to be fast
they have to scale so let's try the
simplest things that we really you know
that we can and see how they work so
really all the high level point is here
is you know we've sort of incremented on
a number of different models first is
this logistic regression then so this
had weights for user IDs and weights for
ad IDs so individual user and individual
ad this is just a iteration on that
where actually there's just a weight on
the click-through rate so there's a
lookup table essentially that says what
is the historical click-through rate for
a given user ID
what's a historical click-through rate
for a given ad ID puts those in and you
know then puts it into this logistic
regression so these are very simple
models very compact and we've tried some
additional things with like boosted
decision trees the problem with this
while at least some more accuracy is
that it is cannot train online as
quickly as some of these other models do
so eventually what Seok Joaquin has a
paper on this that I can refer anyone to
who's interested in in it for
but I'll focus more on the econ side of
this but essentially the the take away
from Joaquin was they really didn't have
any theoretical basis for coming up with
this model of you know boosted decision
trees and then running a regression on
top of that logistic regression
I was just something they tried because
it was so easy to experiment with these
different models and so you know what
what the main takeaway again was just
the ability to try these things so
quickly his has led to you know it being
very easy to explore these different
types of models so this is more a you
know the the practical elements of
prediction rather than having a good
theoretical basis or knowing what it was
in advance okay and one one last
practical aspect is about the so so I
said there's a lot of ads that we have
to make predictions for in a given day
really more than we actually can make
predictions for in practice so we don't
when a given user shows up we don't
predict the probability of a click for
every single ad that we could
potentially be showing to that user
there's some sort of filtering process
that's done and this is essentially just
this is another practical aspect that
was used where so on the x-axis what
we're showing here is the course of a
week and this orange line is the number
of requests that are happening
throughout that time period so you know
you see the cyclic effect is just the
time of day so at night in the US
probably we're just getting fewer
requests and we other otherwise are and
so just the the system it's so easy to
add you know these these different
layers what was done here is just having
some controller that is dynamically
controlling the number of ads that are
ranked based on the number of requests
that are happening at that given time so
if there's fewer requests happening
the middle of the night we can actually
consider making predictions for a larger
number of ads for a given request so
this actually ended up being you know
leading so right so basically what
you're potentially losing by not doing
this is some of these things that you
didn't bother predicting a click-through
rate for actually if you did it you
found out that it was you know a good
thing to show and so we're by having
this sort of dynamic controller we're
able to capture some of this you know
lost value okay so really a qua Keens
main takeaway here I think was I think
I've said it enough but just like you
know experimenting with things and
having the frameworks in place so that
you can very easily try new things and
see if they work in practice and we have
found often times that things that you
know we don't always have good
theoretical basis for the things that we
try but it's just so easy to try them
that sometimes that has actually worked
out pretty well okay any so that's
that's sort of the machine learning side
in a nutshell is there any any questions
on that
okay so next what I'm going to be
talking about so we have these
predictions probabilities of clicks
probabilities of likes now the question
is what do we actually do with them to
decide not just what organic stories to
show but really how to fill out this
entire page when a user comes to
Facebook and so one thing to note is
there's actually three different types
of stories on Facebook so the first
group is these organic stories generated
by users so this is your friend posting
a photo or sharing a video the second
Eric ads right submitted by advertisers
the third are these what we call
long-term value content and so this is
content generated by Facebook that we
think has some positive value on the
ecosystem by by showing this to the user
so it's kind of small but some examples
of this would be it's a lot of
recommendations right so recommendations
for friends which we think will you know
give you and this potential friend
additional content in your feed
recommendations for groups that you
might be interested in joining if you
are an advertiser as well as a user you
might get recommendations about things
that you can do to your improve your ad
campaign maybe adding a conversion pixel
or something like that so really the the
problem that we have is we are going to
take all of this as input these a user
shows up and we have all of these
candidate ads these candidate long-term
value stories and these organic stories
that have been ranked already in the
process I described previously we want
to come up with some allocation and
payment and when we're talking about an
allocation here so now we're in in
Shinmei section so Chinmay is calling
this a configuration I think because
it's I think he's calling it this
because it's not just ads it's really
sort of allocating all of these you know
organic stories and this other content
as well one thing to note here is that
we are
straining the space that we're thinking
about these possible allocations or
configurations the organic stories are
already ranked as input so we do not
consider on the outside
flipping organic stories around we're
only reasoning about inserting organic
stories in between
I'm sorry inserting ads or inserting
these long-term value stories in between
various organic stories not
chronologically good questions so
basically ranked according to you can
think of that the utility this linear
utility function the probability of a
click x well we think the users value of
this click is so we are so that there's
basically some process upstream that is
doing upstream from this ads allocation
problem that is deciding on the ordering
of these organic stories which is based
on this sort of utility function now it
wouldn't have to be like this right we
could throw all of the decide all of
these things at once but this is purely
a simplification for computational
reasons and also just organizational
reasons with it like there's employees
working on these things and you know
it's it's nice to in practice really to
have sort of these module modular areas
that people can work on independently
the coefficients yes yep yep question if
you were to merge them together of
exactly what I mean clearly how good how
engaging the content
these the more likely through something
there scroll down she was saying yes
you're saying like this probably we're
not losing too much by making this
simplification I think you're saying
yeah agreed
yeah it wouldn't it would have to be it
can actually happen but would it would
have to be a weird situation where we
would think that actually is showing
something in a different order than its
originally and would would be better and
so actually maybe this is a good point
too to bring up a difference between
sort of the classical model so yeah so
so some of the things I'd like to sort
of convey here is maybe differences
between what we're doing here and sort
of what the theory you know is normally
the assumptions that are normally being
made and so one thing that is different
here is when you think about a
probability of a click right in most
models there's this separable 'ti of
this advertiser effect so there's some
probability that you know this ad will
be clicked on and then there's this
position effect which is discounting
that this multiplicative effect right so
we we do have that in our model but a
difference which actually complicates
things is we found that different events
have different discount rates so for
example you know the click discount rate
is different from the hiding a story
discount rate and so with this me this
sort of flies in the face of this
cascade model if you think about like
there's some probability that you will
get to this story and then you know it
will have your attention and then given
that it has your attention there's some
probability that you will click or some
probability that you'll do whatever
event so with what we found is that
actually you know that we we do see that
there's different sort of decay rates
for these different events and so really
what this breaks you know fortunately
our you know we we don't have there's a
number of other reasons where it doesn't
matter where we can't just greedily rank
things anyway but but that's what it
would
what it would break essentially it's not
necessarily the case that we can sort of
greedily say this is the best story this
is the second best story this is a third
best story because it depends you know
so some story may prefer one slot and
some other story may prefer some other
slot if you know one of them has a high
probability of getting clicked and the
other has a high probability of some
other event but that decays in a
different way so that's I guess that's
maybe takeaway number one is that this
is sort of one assumption that is
typically made that that we are not
making and it adds some additional
complications to what we're doing okay
any other questions ok so ok so this is
our problem now is coming up with this
configuration so how do we do this we we
actually run a VCG auction and so so
Chinmay says VCG auction is a necessity
here I think really what he's saying is
is that GSP will not handle this problem
right because if you look at these
different stories for one they're of
different sizes and for - they're for -
there's various additional constraints
on the essentially the ordering of
things that we can show for instance
will never show an ad and then a friend
recommendation and then an ad so if
there's going to be a friend
recommendation we'll put it on will sort
of make these things distinct it's about
friend recommendations and then ads so
so we don't have this model even if we
wanted to it doesn't really fit into the
the GSP slot model and so this is
basically for those of you unfamiliar
there's sort of two places that we're
putting these stories so one is on the
right-hand side here and this is sort of
some fixed length but individual ads can
have different sizes second is the the
feed this is where you know
that this is where we're spending most
of our time thinking about it's a much
larger portion of our revenue
but so the properties here again we have
these different stories that are of
different sizes and this is essentially
some infinitely essentially infinitely
long page and what we're thinking about
when a user loads the page we are sort
of plopping if we think about those
inputs we're sort of plopping these
organic stories on the top and now we're
thinking about how to insert these
sponsored stories but but considering
how that is actually decreasing the
value of displacing value of everything
else that's potentially on the page and
so to make things even more complicated
so we also have horizontally scrollable
slots essentially so so it's not just
that we're putting ads within this feed
top to top to bottom but there's also an
individual story can go left to right
and also have yeah potential ads go in
there so why VCG I think this audience
will be ok with with this reasoning so
value maximizing and incentive
compatible now we put an asterisk by
instead of compatible because really we
need its instead of compatible with some
assumptions holding that may not
actually hold in practice and so this is
sort of a question we're actively
thinking about is you know in reality
how incentive compatible are these
auctions but then from the engineering
perspective it's also useful to have
this because it is you know general just
you know we introduced some horizontal
scrolling ads and there's not any
question really about what the
allocation rule is going to be we
already know what it is so really we're
just pushing all of the hard work into
this coming up with some optimization
that will find this optimal allocation
okay so very quickly this is really this
is just describing VCG right so we I
guess in our context a little bit so we
have some set of agents and we have some
set of configurations so these are just
possible allocations that we could have
and so there's some value that a so this
right hand side is the value that a
given agent has for some configuration
and there's some total value for the
configuration which is just the sum of
all of the individual values right and
so of course you know VCG we're just
trying to choose this value maximizing
configuration and an individual agent
we're just going to charge them their
externalities so let's remove them let's
rerun this algorithm and let's see how
everybody else's value is different now
there's a question so the first question
is how do we actually come up with this
value that an ad has for a given
configuration and I've touched on it a
little bit with this you know utility
function value of click probability of
click but there's other rules as well
some of which are just saying that we
don't want a given user to see too many
ads and so there's basically some
business logic that goes in potentially
changing the values of various
configurations in addition this is sort
of thinking about a single auction in
isolation but of course there's these
cross auction dependencies such as
budget constraints that are also going
to play into what we think about is an
individual bid and then yeah so so given
these values then of course we have to
solve this optimization problem and so
really over here we said incentive
compatible had an asterisk but we could
put in an asterisk next to value
maximizing as well because we're we're
trying to find the optimal allocation
but you know we're taking many shortcuts
that are not actually going to find it
in practice but we're doing our best to
fine
that so this is yes you yep user comes
loads the the fee if there's some new
stories there's this upstream thing
that's deciding on this ranking of
organic stories and then we're going to
run VCG to decide where to put these
sponsored stories and these long-term
value stories both in feed and on the
right hand side that's right so it's for
on an individual query level basis yeah
that's a good good good point no so we
don't do anything like that so there's
sort of this process of you know because
we can't consider all these ads at once
there's this candidate set and then yeah
once we remove that ad we don't try to
get some new ad from the candidate set
yeah I don't know how much hopefully it
wouldn't make that big of a difference
because it would just the only time
would make a difference is if this one
ad was on the margin where it actually
would show up but I don't think anyone's
tried to say for sure if that would make
a difference or not
okay and so a right so so we've said
that advertisers can express values for
these different objectives some
advertiser might care about page clicks
someone else might care about
conversions to their website so the
first thing that we do is just convert
all of these values for these different
events into some common unit essentially
so some underlying value for a given say
impression so that there's essentially
some bid for an event some probability
of a given events and so the value
function again is just this dot product
to the to the vector of per event bids
times these probabilities okay
okay so one other twist here
from sort of the classic sponsored story
or sorry sponsored search model is you
know we do have these organic stories
that were inserting these ads amongst
and so you know we can say how the value
has changed for this particular
advertiser that has specified this value
but these this utility in for these
organic stories is not in terms of
dollars right and so one thing that we
have to do is actually come up with some
monetary value for these utility you
know this utility that we've come up
with for a given story and similarly
another difference is that a given story
a sponsored story there's some
probability that the user may say hi did
that sponsored story right so so even
sponsored stories so there's some
advertiser value for that story being
shown in this position but there's also
the user value for seeing this ad in
this position so if we think there's
some probability that the user is going
to hide this particular story that's
essentially a negative bid a you know
that is going into this this Sponsored
Stories bid
okay so that's what I just described
here
so yes so this is essentially what we're
doing is it's not just about the value
that the advertisers have for these
different stories appearing in different
places we're sort of placing bids on
behalf of the user or the ecosystem for
these different stories appearing in
different places okay so any questions
on that so that's sort of looking at
this from a single auction perspective
and now we'll address some of these
aspects where you know maybe we can't
look at a single auction in isolation
yeah that's a good question so I I can't
tell you a number but I can give you
sort of qualitatively how we do that and
that will come up and I think three
slides good question all right so so one
of the these cross auction dependencies
of course which is common and sponsored
search as well is budget optimization
right so so this is the interface that
an advertiser has and down on the bottom
here the advertiser is specifying some
bid for clicks up top they're specifying
some budget some amount they're wanting
to spend
so this advertisers wanting to spend
$700 starting June 9th for lasting about
a week so so this is really I think this
is not this actually is not unique to
Facebook this is just you know sponsored
search also has this problem but we'll
say what we're doing here to handle this
so so right if we think about this
particular bid that that advertiser has
expressed if we entered that bid in all
of these auctions it may turn out that
the advertiser spends its budget half
way through its campaign all right so
this is time on the x-axis you can think
of each of these dots as just being an
auction that was happening at that time
and this if you know even think about
these is like you know single slot
auctions or something like that where
this is just the price that the the
advertiser will pay if he's bidding more
than that right so it could be that this
advertiser is exhausting its budget
halfway through the day
this is bad for a couple reasons one is
just potentially expectations this
advertiser may be intending to have its
budget being spent throughout the entire
period but also it could be that if if
the advertiser actually has the same
value for all these different clicks
happening you know it would prefer to
not be paying that high amount for a
click up there when it could have been
lower and received a click here there's
sort of two ways that this is handled so
one is this problem of probabilistic
pacing so we'll choose some multiplier
and basically probabilistically have
this ad going to the auction
trying to find this multiplier
essentially that exhausts the budget
over you know so it spends it smoothly
over the course of the period we
actually do something different which is
this multiplicative version and so
instead of probabilistic we just scale
the bit down so that the budget is spent
in this time period though there's
arguments for both of these it's not I
don't think that this is just strictly
dominating the other it really depends
on what assumptions you're making about
the value that advertisers are having
here right so if it's actually not the
case that let's say the the advertiser
is bidding for clicks but it actually
cares about conversions right and it may
be the case that for one reason or
another maybe demographics are different
in you know for these higher bids it's
more females versus males or maybe
there's a common value element but it
could be that actually the probabilistic
version would be better but so so
basically you know this this is an
optimal thing to do under some
assumptions about the underlying values
that that advertisers are having for for
clicks
and to get to the point that was made
about what is the actual value that
we're thinking about for the organic
side so this is sort of another cross
auction dependency that I think I think
the analog really works well with the
the analog is the budget pacing
essentially where we have this
multiplier that's scaling the bid up and
down to try to get the budget spent
smoothly over this period
similarly the intuition is that a user
is going to be you know have a more
negative reaction to ads the more and
more ads that it's seeing so basically
we have a controller on the organic bid
so we're scaling it up and down based on
how many ads it is seen previously so
this is sort of a control bull for the
quality that the advertiser is getting
and it's also sort of subsuming reserve
prices in a sense as well because if we
you know scaling this up higher is
causing this some advertiser to have
more displaced it's displacing more
value when the ad actually is shown
hey this [ __ ] will be there
does he freedom to book them right on
the bottom right oh the the right hand
side yes yep yep so it's basically you
could think of it as any given story you
know whether it's an ad or otherwise has
this organic component regardless of
where it shows up and yeah we'll scale
that up and down based on how many ads
users see if the control loop roughly
keeping the number of ads roughly
constant across users or is this some
extra loop that decides how many ads
each user should see yeah good question
so this is we're not choosing to have
some yeah so it's the former with so
basically we do not want just because
some user is more valuable to
advertisers than others we don't want
that particular user to just be swamped
with ads so it is sort of a you know
there's some amount of ads essentially
that a given user should be able to see
and so will will change this accordingly
so the one friend had like oh I see what
you're saying yeah so that's sort of
like in this murky middle ground like is
it an ad or is it a story so that is an
ad but this is with some I don't
remember what we call it internally but
it's some additional context that
basically we may think that you're more
likely to like this thing or click on
this thing because we're giving you some
additional signal that yes yep yep
big lowering and throttling are so
different shoots every times will
actually decide yes yeah that's a good
good question and so I think if you look
at I think that's a feature that that
perhaps we could implement so really I
think the the whole perspective that
we're taking really is nothing to do
with trying to extract revenue we're
really trying to have this system that
is providing as much value to
advertisers and users as we can and so
this seems like sort of the the areas
for improvement is like figuring out how
we can better allow advertisers to
easily either easily express their
preferences or yet so either they can
express their preferences right now but
it's just challenging to do so or maybe
the language doesn't even allow them to
express that underlying value so we do
have now some like incremental version
towards that where you do not have to be
paste so you don't need this
multiplicative pacing to go down as far
as I know I don't think we offer
probabilistic pacing but it at least
allows advertisers to sort of do this on
their own
whereas before if they wanted to do this
you know set an extremely high budget so
that you you know essentially are not
going to have your bid discounted and
sort of you know you're sort of jumping
through hoops to you know making
advertiser jump through hoops to do that
they want to do so as much as we can
remove that from the system and making
making things easier for advertisers the
better off I think will be
so--that's yes so that's sort of this
summary of what we're doing on the
machine learning side of predicting
these different events and then how
we're actually using that to decide what
we're going to show - you know what
these allocations and payments are going
to be I'm happy to chat with anyone
about this I think there's a lot of
interesting problems even just
understanding that last point about you
know what is this system currently not
capturing that advertisers care about
and how can we identify this from the
data and you know second is just you
know the actually implementing some of
these features and understanding what
you know what is not being captured
right now so thank you very much
I yeah so I did not mean that we're
considering some different mechanism but
rather it's more an empirical question
right so there's a number of assumptions
that would need to hold for incentive
compatibility actually to hold for
instance we are actually predicting
these different click-through rates and
things like that correctly it would be
one of them and so yeah so it's more
about understanding in the current
system even if you said that you know
the underlying values are expressible
like there is some single value for a
click and some value for a like and we
can set have these things separable is
it actually you know even in that case
can an advertiser do they have
incentives to be you know changing their
their bids so it's more an empirical
question rather than coming up with some
new mechanism mechanism because really
the solution I think is just providing
the expressiveness that would allow the
advertiser to
press their values and once you have
that then you can just run VCG right so
that's that's really I think what the
challenge is
so when you talk about probabilistic
smoothing I believe that for one end
what happened when you perform that for
multiple ends or one options what they
have is some kind of we interactions way
you just one time for move oh man
because yeah so I suppose that is an
issue so I should say that we're we're
not doing probabilistic pacing just to
be clear we're doing a multiplicative
version well yeah so I suppose that so
maybe I don't know if anyone who's doing
probabilistic pacing wants to comment on
this but I'm guessing that's just an
issue that comes up if you're treating
these is just independence probabilities
that maybe sometimes you get that draw
so the the question was so we're doing
this multiplicative pacing but the
question was with probabilistic pacing
the concern was that sometimes maybe you
get you know say there's two ads that
have a probability less than one and
sometimes it just so happens that
neither of these ads ends up being
eligible just by the unfortunate luck of
the draw and so I I think maybe you were
asking if it is actually these
independent draws or if maybe there's
something joint that is done that's
trying to avoid that yeah so the answer
to that is just we're not doing
probabilistic pacing so maybe we'll have
to think about that if we you know
because advertisers potentially do value
this I think
but at least you're not having this
situation where nobody is participating
right it's just people are lowering
their bids
thank you very much